let's give a big ol clap it up to this
girl this woman on tick-tock that girl
grown-ass woman on tick-tock gettin a
[ __ ] NFC reader in her palm and
everyone free oh so good I didn't even
watch the video because I wanted to save
it for the podcast yeah but can you turn
on the screen sharing oh yeah yeah yeah
so I can see this whoops that's my dick
sorry dude it's a full-screen picture of
dick just a big ol on your PC oh sorry
bro I was photoshopping that hair oh man
I was trying to extend it a little bit
huh bro have you seen that Twitter video
of the dude thought it was a tick tock
right where he does panorama on his
finger and he's like boys yep yeah so
good I watched it I had to try it just
just to see what would happen it looks
it looked I was like dying laughing
doing panorama to my dick and laughing
at how warped you can make it it's got
like a ass in the middle fellas you got
to do that [ __ ] you gotta you got a you
got to do the panorama but [ __ ] it up
like yeah yeah who got all I've walk-in
as monsters yeah and and in our pants
completely bees Stoneface serious about
it be like what that's like that's what
it is yeah what is what if what if what
do other dudes look like you're good
dude gives you emit that would be so
[ __ ] funny to actually whip out like
a bendy straw like a loopy straw dick
where it's like some crazy shave oh my
god like send me send me a pic let's see
it lets see it how big is it like all
right send it off it's got a full loop
de loop in it [ __ ] look like a tuba it's
just looking its
like a French horn yeah crazy waterslide
dick it's what I was thinking of a
French horn but not the circular part
it's the part in the middle yeah that's
all good and the end is the same that's
just a turtle dick the turtle dick looks
like a [ __ ] French horn it's crazy
it's actually it's actually when I had
the name for the turtle dick that's the
non scientific name the French horn oh
[ __ ]
anyways alright okay I'll say I've
brought this up before I've watched the
video on people that do this but anyway
[Music]
I got chip today and it's freaking hurt
oh my gosh my hands icky are you kidding
me we talked about this before people
just get that like an NFC thing in there
and [ __ ] unlock doors and that like
that's it like it doesn't have any real
real interesting use no it does they
just don't know what it is okay all
right all right all right no I'm saying
it's interesting for the government oh
yeah yeah it's not it nah it'll you know
forever for them just be unlocking their
door that's know completely and this is
and it'll never lose its appeal to them
either this is how do it for years and
every time will be like the first time
today off that's so [ __ ] cool
meanwhile the government is just
scraping data about their [ __ ] what
they're doing bro that I mean truly this
is how it starts this is how the [ __ ] it
starts there's you know it's it was
gonna be some dumb [ __ ] like this is it
I was looking into what is it so BMW now
they offer the ability to authorize
digital keys so you can pass a digital
key to someone to like move your car and
you can like set boundaries for it so it
can't be driven a certain distance and
yeah I looked at that and I said oh yeah
here we go there and then give it two
years you walk into the dealership they
go yeah and we can put it in your hand
yeah oh I'm a techie I would love that
but I love my my techie husband oh that
word my techie husband decided to give
me a chip he's always messing with
devices he gets every new iPod that
comes out he's such a techie and then I
guess we get it we're getting chipped
because he's a techie yeah techie just
means you [ __ ] know how to use an
Alexa yeah any any like actual techie
would know you should never [ __ ] do
this ever yeah in a million years
here's the thing though like I say I say
you should never do this but I'm all
also being hypocritical when I say
that because got an Apple watch Apple
watch I mean we carry our phones
everywhere we go yes I know I said the
Elan chip would be a good thing yeah his
neural link channel yep because he makes
the point he's like we're already
chipped everyone brings these shits
around wherever they go no matter what
and if you don't you feel like you're
empty when you're without your device
yeah I'm never I'm never without my
device unless I'm surfing but even then
I have an Apple watch on yes I'm never
without anything we're already [ __ ]
chips we might as well just [ __ ] put
them in our skin mm-hmm so I don't know
a counterpoint I remember trying to
bring our points everything yeah that's
fine you know
you